you like surfing I do I'm not great at
it but I suck at it but if I can tow it
into some 30 Footers wow
um Kawaii it's funny man it is my least
liked picture I like like risk my life
before and the guy that I'm like with
it's like yeah [__] yeah man it's firing
today let's go out he's like I got a
local friend that'll like tell us in I'm
like I'm like I like what's the danger
level on that he's like ah you'll be
good dude you've been you've been
preparing for this your whole life I'm
like what are you talking about he's
like you've been wakes up you're good
I'm like [__] it let's go and so we're
like driving out there and the guy um
the guy black bear was his name he's
like um he was he was talking to me
about it he's like so he's like you know
you've done this before right I'm like
no not really it's like what's the
biggest wave you surf I'm like oh I mean
I got like the [__] beat out of me I'm
like some 10 or 12 Footers but I didn't
really like surf any of them you know
he's like so like what are you doing
like I don't know he said this is safe
and the black bear looks over my buddy's
like what he's like you could get
[__] killed he's like man he's like
this is like a [__] engine piston
like it'll Force you down to the bottom
before your eardrums out like he's like
you can hold your breath for a while
right I'm like not really I'm like maybe
like a minute he's like oh man he's like
you sure you want to do this and I'm
like we're like almost there I'm like I
don't know should I he's like probably
not and my buddy's like don't be a
[__] [__] anyways long story short I
go out and I do this and surf these
[__] ways it's kind of similar to
like wakeboarding which I had done my
whole life because you're strapped in
but you're going like 50 miles an hour
like you're [__] skipping across the
water and there's and it's not like a
smooth Lake right there's like [__]
chop I mean it's a goddamn ocean so I'm
like skipping across waves you know
within the wave at like 50 miles an hour
knowing that if I eat [__] I'm like
probably [__] decent chance of dying
and I got you know like a few pictures
of it and posted and it was like my
least liked photo ever on it yeah nobody
gives a crap about me
I don't care I'm like in a million
dollar truck jumping 100 feet they're
like whatever man big tits they're
smashing the like buttons
yeah like uh I flew four planes five
planes of Madagascar took a photo
surfing it got whatever likes I take a
picture of Steve sleeping on the on the
plane that gets like tens of thousands
of likes it's like wait wait
like
it's probably setting up like an
Instagram you get an idea for an
Instagram photo and you're like okay
we're gonna we're gonna set this up I'll
never do it man I yeah I mean like maybe
for ignite or something but like yeah I
just try and have my [__] just very
organic and authentic I feel like the
internet is very good at like seeing
through [__] like there have been
some stuff like you know we did a photo
shoot for like Christmas you know where
I got like two chicks and I got a
[__] thing so there's gonna be like
some where it's like four something but
99 of the stuff that I post is just like
candid shots like okay like I happen to
be with like eight super hot chicks on a
[__] tank with like a bazooka so like
this is the time the tank one was
definitely a setup spot but I did rent
the tank and I drove over the car you
know but um yeah the picture that I
posted was one where I'm just like
sitting on the thing and yeah um but
yeah man it's like you know for me I I
wanted and I told my camera guy this
early on I'm like I just want to like do
this [__] and you capture it if you
don't capture it like it's gone you know
what I mean so try and capture it
because we're not gonna redo it we're
not gonna you know set up shots
because to me man all that [__] is just
not authentic I see a lot of guys trying
to copy this [__] that I do and it's
like okay let's get like eight models
here and you know and every in the all
the girls are looking at the camera and
it's just like you just know it's a shot
that like everybody had like set up and
it's not cool you know like perceived
effort it's like it's pretty cool well I
mean yet they're [__] them but not
they're just like paying these [__]
to sit around them so for an Instagram
photo like that's not cool like if it's
like post orgy then cool you know what I
mean but like I'll give you that but
that's what I'm saying the authenticity
you know what I mean like these guys are
like posted chicks they're not [__]
like I'm not posting girls I'm not
[__] you know what I mean like yeah
yeah so I mean like if it's a group
photo I didn't always [__] every chick
in the group but I'm saying like if I'm
posting a girl my Instagram is a chick
that I'm [__] you know like it's not
like yeah Integrity yeah exactly
it's posted a picture of another man's
car like you don't do it you know so
like I had like rules you know like what
I was gonna do and I think that's why
like you know I mean I've been doing
this [__] for like 10 years you know
like yeah like and you look like old
school like you know I mean you're my
generation like these [__] people
that
um you know they were in Hollywood I
mean usually like they had like five
years you know of like a run rate and
social media's change it like you can
kind of like be out there for a long
time now you know like because you're
just constantly in people's faces
whereas movie stars they do a movie six
months later it comes out people watch
it it's two hours and then it's like you
know it's done right so like for them to
kind of like stay in the spotlight it
was it was more difficult the games
changed you know so yeah dude it's
gnarly man I've been I've been at this
for
yeah I've seen it on your seat bites a
bunch like uh when there's big fights in
in Vegas are you doing like after
parties at this compound
no man I I mean definitely not for UFC
I've never done anything for UFC fights
I just I've always been a fan of the
sport I was doing Jiu Jitsu actually
before UFC one came out so yeah yeah so
I've been kind of like in that whole
thing and I remember when the first one
came out and it's funny man I've
actually been able to spot stuff like
this pretty well like I was like this is
gonna be [__] the [__] you know
people are gonna watch this and
everybody's like no [__] way you know
and like I remember when the first Maxim
magazine came out I was like this is
going to be cool you know so like I've
been able to spot some stuff pretty good
but UFC was definitely one of them where
I was like man I love it it's like it's
like the age-old question right like
when we were kids like who's winning a
fight Batman or Superman
yeah like who's gonna win the [__]
you know the the the boxer or the
[__] you know the the martial artist
like nobody knew like when we grew up
nobody knew nobody knew who the badass
was nobody knew who really would win you
know and this actually like showed you
who's gonna [__] win there's a lot of
guys that talk [__] a lot of guys that
hit mitts and look good on the mitts but
like who's gonna actually win enough
life right all we had was Hulk Hogan
versus Rocky yeah exactly exactly the
[__] fights you know and so this is
the the real deal man and uh yes I I
loved it I've always been a fan of that
sport Dad I'm I'm scared of uh the idea
of being at one of your parties but I
also really want to I never came to
anything yeah like and that now we're
linked up dude if you have a if you're
having a party man uh dude shoot me a
text man that'd be killer man I hate to
[__] throw you off the wagon but ah
dude I'm pretty solid like oh yeah I'll
make sure I come with a sober buddy yeah
yeah
[Applause]
like right out of the book like do you
have a legitimate reason for being there
it's like
yeah they're debaucherous man I [__] man
I remember some of those parties were
just it was just absolute Mayhem yeah
dude and it was just it was it was a it
was a cool thing because it was like I
grew up and the whole Playboy era you
know before they [__] killed it with
the [__] one-legged fat chicks trying
to be inclusive you know like I remember
when it was like legit you know and Hugh
Hefner was doing his thing and it was
just always like a dream line to go to
one of those parties and like be a part
of that scene and I feel like I actually
did it you know to a higher level you
know like sure you did like [__] he
never had three thousands you know what
I mean like there was this and I was
adamant about the girls that came to
these parties you know what I mean like
there was a [__] like strict like cut
off you know it was like the chick was
overweight or she was you know not
wearing lingerie I mean they were just
you know [__] shut them out right at
the thing I mean I'm there was like
girls in the driveway like wrapped
around the thing like taking off all
their [__] clothes because the
laundry party it was like the guy's like
I give a [__] if you're Emily radakowski
you're not getting in here unless you're
in [__] lingerie so they'd be
stripping their clothes off
gotta have integrity yeah yeah get a
little chicken address it [__] it up do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude